aussi parler de briit Maron la première
dame s livré à Paris Match elle s livré
comme
jamais
braoré
par comm
àirad
parle
dans les années 90 Emmanuel Macron
rencontre Brigitte trogneux qui est
alors sa professeur de théâtre
c'est marié avec le président de la
République depuis 2007 Brigitte Macron
vient d'accorder une interview au
magazine Paris Match où elle se livre
comme rarement si elle revient notamment
sur lesécardage avec Emmanuel Macron
pour moi un garçon si jeune c'était
rédiibitoire dans cette entretien la
première dame ass aussi formé avec son
mari un couple presque normal ilès tous
les deux toujours que quelque fois elle
fait la cuisine alors que dit-elle dans
cet entretien différence d'âge plat
préféré vie quotidienne retour sur les
incroyable confession de Brigitte Macron
dans Paris
Match bravo bravo à Paris Match vraiment
très très très interview très forte et
bravo à Brigitte Macron moi j'adoris
voilà je vous le dis et je sais que
voilà j'ai voilà j'ai trouvé enfin il se
passe quelque chose sur Paris Match
bravo et voilà ça fait pl SC monumental
quand même la prière dame pr justement
comment ils sont rencontrés Emmanuel et
Brigitte bon alors oui un SCOP
monumental donc comment ils se sont
rencontrés ben en fait elle
était elle était elle pilotait il était
donc au lycée La Providence piloter
attends je vais finir elle pilotait un
stage de théâtre au
lyé
av croyais en commandant
de non donc voilà elle elle proposait un
stage de théâtre et puis Emmanuel Macron
qui était dans la même classe que sa
fille hein sa fille Laurence puisque à
l'époque il avait 15 ans et sa fille
aussi avait 15 ans Brigitte Macron elle
elle en avait 39 bah là il se rend
compte et puis bah c'est le coup de
foudre he ce qu'elle explique dans Paris
Match et qu'elle a déjà dit avant donc
le coup de foudre exactement on peut on
peut avoir des juste non mais juste on
sait que il était il adorait le théâtre
il sa certainement qu'il adore encore
mais en tous les cas il était très
éloquent et très facile et et donc là
qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu il y a eu quoi g
raconte-nous bien envie de savoir
comment ça s pécha bordel non mais elle
dit pas vraiment comment ça s elle dit
des
trucs non elle dit qu'il a 15 ans elle
c'est bon pas Michel Marie laisse parler
v-y elle est mariée elle a trois enfants
peu de temps après son père va décéder
elle parle de l'ouragan intérieur c'est
comment faire pour concilier cet amour
pour un jeune homme beaucoup plus jeune
qu'elle par rapport à ses enfants auqu
elle renonce d'Ille voilà elle renonce
dans un premier temps et puis après elle
dit que il me faut le temps d'élever mes
enfants de les responsabiliser de leur
parler 10 ans c'estàdire qu'elle prend
10 ans pour que ses enfants puissent
entendre tout ce qui se pass son tout de
suite tombé amourux il y a eu un coup de
foudre ah oui tout de suite comme on dit
quandelle elle pr 10 ans elle a pas
attendu 10 ans pour sortir avec Emmanuel
Macron il est parti à Paris pour changer
concrètement sa vie il part à Paris
voilà exactement raconz-nous con est
parti à Paris elle a espéré qu'il tombe
amoureux de quelqu'un de son âge quand
il était à Paris tout fait quand même
pour voilà pour résister elle dit à un
garçon de cet âge là c'était rédibitoire
mais c'était le bazar dans ma tête elle
dit des choses fortes dans cette FEM
oublié elle dit une femme oublié c'est
sûr il va tomber amoureux et non pas du
tout oui mais oui c'est franchement
c'est beau Miriam non mais c'est vrai
c'est c'est une belle histoire d'amour
r non mais pas l'Our mais on est on est
là en fin d' Olivé une toi tu es là pour
tu es là pour donner les fait bon alors
les faits donc je te le dis elle le rend
compte donc c'est en 1992
1993 voilà elle donne un cours de
théâtre il se il là il y a un flash
parce qu'elle trouve qu'effectivement
c'est le le l'étudiant le plus brillant
de de de de la session du coup lui il
part ensuite à Paris elle espère
effectivement comme l'a dit g que
qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle partte qu' tombe
amoureux à Paris bon et puis s'avère que
bah il tombe pas amoureux elle aussi va
donner des cours à Paris et là ils
reprennent leur leur histoire là où il
l'avait laissé fort fort euh et il se
marie en 2007 et il se marie en 2007 le
20 octobre donc elle faisait quoi donc
Brigit avant avant elle était attachée
de presse pour la chambre des commerces
du du Nord patcalais et puis quand son
premier mari a été muté elle a décidé de
passer son capèce et et du coup elle est
devenue prof sur le tard et les enfants
de Brigitte Macron ils étaient comment
par rapport au mariage Patrick bah par
rapport au aux trois
enfants elle explique qu'elle a dû gérer
alors elle ne décrit pas l'état d'esprit
de ses enfants mais elle explique
qu'elle elle a pas voulu les mettent
dans cette situation pas saccager leur
vie mais oui c'était pas facile pour eux
parce que de voir cet homme beaucoup
plus jeune 24 ans d'écart donc comment
ils allaient se situer et cetera c'est
pour ça qu'elle a pris 10 ans pour que
ses enfté ça a été très difficile au
sein de la famille hein le le le le
Jean-Louis osierre a très mal pris la
chose les parents d'Emmanuel Macron
également très mal pris l'histoire et
c'était dans dans à Amien c'était
extrêmement mal vue cette relation était
extrêmement mal vue alors euh donc euh
elle donne des cours encore aujourd'hui
alors elle donne des cours là elle
justement c'est ce qu'exlique Paris
Match elle donne de des cours dans le
cadre d'une association qu'elle a monté
avec avec comment avec Bernard Arnaud et
du coup elle donne elle continue à
donner des cours donc là le évidemment
Paris Match et dit TI en bque en disant
qu'elle a la passion qu'elle a le feu
que ça se voit que c'était une super
prof et cetera
elle
moi ce qu'onend on va vous dire ce qu'on
apprend dans par tu m'as mis calme-toi
euh elle se dépasse toujours avec uel
Macron euh non pas toujours pas toujours
non non non pas toujours ce qu'elle
explique dans dans l'interview c'est que
ils font leur emploi du temps quand ils
vont le weekend à la lanterne donc voilà
ils font son emploi du temps mais elle
aussi c'est quelqu'un de très occupé
donc ils se mettent d'accord sur les
allées venues qu'elle va faire avec lui
ou pas est-ce qu'ils prennent toujours
le petit- déjeuner en alors ça c'est la
partie que je préfère dans l'interview
c'est que c'est que donc on nous
explique enfin cette interview est
magistrale on nous explique donc elle
lui prépare le
petit-déjeuner démarrer plein plein
voilà e Manu viens voir avec Ben
démar le matin au petit déjeuner non non
elle explique que du coup elle regarde
parce qu'elle est super il y a des ouais
il y a des il y a des super recettes
dans marmiton et que Manu adore les œufs
à la coque je sais donc et ailleurs ça
fait très parce que dans l'interview il
y a une parenthèse où la journaliste dit
on ne sait pas si Brigitte met du beurre
sur les petites mouillettes d'Emmanuel
Mac on le SAA j'espère à la prochaine
interview ouais donc c'est le truc le
petit déjeuner ensemble c'est quoi qu'il
arrive quoi qu'il arrive c'est petit
déjeuner ensemble alors ce qu'elle
explique c'est que c'est le moment il
est c'est le moment où il est plus sympa
il par qu' adore il adore les chocop
poops non s quel choc chocopops W
W non il adore ça il adore ça c'est le
moment où il est plus sympa bah c'est ce
qu'elle dit c'est le moment où il est
plus sympa il est jamais de mauvaise
humeur le matin donc je sais pas comment
il le dîner il d ensemble tous les alors
il d t d ensemble tous les soirs alors
là ils expliqueent que c'est 22h 23h
pour le dîner parce que
évidemment évidemment Emmanuel est très
très occupé donc donc voilà il vers
22h30 23h ouais mais léger c'est ce qui
est dit dans l'interview oui léger très
léger toujours c'est Brigitte qui fait
la cuisine non de temps en temps de
temps en temps de temps en tempsoi de
temps en temps bah de temps en temps
c'est pas vrai et est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron il cuisine parfois euh je ne
crois pas non Gill s'il te
plaît c'est pas dit mais je crois pas il
y a un truc marrant c'est qu'il prennent
le petit- dééjeuner enensemble semble
mais elle explique que elle ne donne
jamais son avis le matin elle dit c'est
pas le bon moment le matin pour lu par
j'ai quelque chose à dire à Emmanuel ce
n'est jamais le matin quand j'ai un avis
je l'exprime évidemment celui-ci n'est
pas toujours suivi c'est là où c'est pas
c'est pas très clair dans l'interview
parce que justement elle dit qu'elle ne
donne jamais son avis son elle lui
demande jamais rien le matin et en même
temps elle explique que c'est le matin
qu'il est le plus sympa justement elle
le laisse tranquille oui alors du
couput
pas tend quand on peut se dire je t'aime
être
euh merci euh non il y a aussi un truc
très qu'elle est proche de certains
ministres alors oui c'est ce qu'elle
explique
hein givia elle explique donc ce n'est
pas une femme politique mais elle
déjeunne régulièrement avec avec les les
les les les ministres hein alors donc
avec Aurore berger Gabriel attane
superbe ministre de la Santé monsieur
Rousseau voilà donc donc donc voilà
tenezv
fait arrêtez de Don votre amis
réaliste et donc elle elle donc elle
raconte que voilà elle est que voilà
elle elle est intéressée par tous les
dossiers notamment les dossiers pour
l'enfance le handicap et que et que
voilà déjeunne régulièrement avec on l'
voy on l' voyant en photo derrière vous
tout à l'heure avec Gabriel Atal c'est
vrai que son son engagement principal
c'est la lutte contre le harcèlement et
ça elle en parle beaucoup elle dit
qu'elle est mobilisée auprès de lui et
cetera et c'est vrai que c'est une cause
elle ne se cont pas d'être potiche c'est
pas du tout une première dame potiche
elle s'engage sur cette cause du
harcèlement avec toute sa vigueur et ça
on ne peut que louer ça parce que c'est
une cause essentielle doré blanquaire et
elle a été très surprise quand il y a eu
la nomination de papendelle a apprise
comme ça et elle était pas forcément
pour ouais c'est vrai mais elle n'a rien
dit bien sûr ah oui bien sûr bien sûr
c'est qui son ministre préféré à priori
c'est Gabri c'était blanit blan son
ministre préféré mais elle s'entend très
bien avec Gabriel ça fait partiees
petits chouous ouais très très bien oua
alors j'adorais moi ce qu'elle a dit
parce qu'on va revenir làdessus le SE
obstacle était mes enfants j'ai pris du
temps pour ne pas saccager leur vie ça a
duré 10 ans le temps de les mettre sur
les rails
ouais imaginer ce qu'ils ont entendu
mais moi je ne voulais pas passer à côté
de ma vie c'est beau oui c'est moi ce
que j'ai bien aimé dans l'interview vous
arrêtez vous pardon non ce que j'aime
bien dans l'interview dans ce qu'elle
dit c'est que plein de gens peuvent
s'identifier en différentes parties
c'est vrai que les familles recomposé
c'est extrêmement compliqué comment
gérer les enfants comment faire pour que
ils soient pas que leur vie soit pas
brisée soit
pas impacter donc je trouve c'est
intéressant parce que c'est une
interview concrète presque de vie
quotidienne évidemment c'est le coup
présidentiel mais c'est pour ça que ça
touche beaucoup cette interview en moi
ça m' touché dit nous sommes un couple
normal il nous arrive de ne pas être
d'accord j'ai l'influence qu'une femme
peut avoir sur son mari voilà on sent
qu'il s'engueule qui sont pas d'accord
que là elle dit clairement que de temps
en temps elle est pas en face sur les
sur les décisions et qu'elle reste à sa
place donc je trouve que c'est bien
parce que c'est effectivement la vie
d'un couple normal qui n'est pas normal
mais qui essaie de l'atre dans sa vie de
le couple elle dit également que
Emmanuel Macron donc adore les œufs à la
coque oui
ouais oui c'est ça je confirme je
confirme il adore les œuf à la coque et
c'est elle qui lui prépare le matin
c'est que le matin c'est le matin
visible et pas le pas le soir non pas le
soir le soir c'est très léger donc
apparemment c'est plutôt
une voilà une soupe et et de la saladep
au lit une
fougace oui qu'est-ce que et oui il fait
attention aussi à sa à sa ligne il fait
du sportou il fait du sport alors oui 45
minutes d'entraînement tous les joue
deux fois par semaine de la box des
étirements du gainage c'est un homme
très sportif il faut il faut se
maintenir en forme quand on
weekend
Bou dans la résidence présidentielle et
lui elle dit qu'il a
dessa à versa la résidence
présidcoup Nicolas sarzi qui l'a remis à
l'honneur par qu'avant c'était quelque
chose qui était occupé par diffes
personnes et c'est Nicolas SAR qui a ça
reviendrait une résidence de weekend du
couple présidentiel donc exp ces
weekends là il reçoit énormément de de
courriers il a d'énormes parafur qui
arrivent et que donc il passe son temps
voilà à tout signer et organiser son
agenda c'est il y a un passage aussi
très intéressant sur le relation avec le
Cloup Royal anglais c'est ça avec
Charles et Charles et Camila ils
s'entendent très bien elle dit que mais
oui elle dit que lui est entre
de les deux femmes le cour est passé
tout de suite que lui est très drôle
très sympa et justement elle dit que
c'est important aussi d'avoir des
relations avec les autres premières
dames avec la première dame turque par
exemple madame Erdogan c'est très
surprenant ça elle dit qu'elle est très
sympa qu'elle s'entend très bien avec
elle mais oui elle parle aussi de
Mélania elle dit qu'elle a un fort
caractère et que d'ailleurs c'est très
drôle parce que quand ils se sont
retrouvés à dîner avec avec Donald Trump
et méania bah c'est elle qui qui fait
tourner la la la machine et quand elle
tape comme ça sur sa monte ça veut dire
allez on y va faut faut rentrer mon
chéri donc elle expque contrairement aux
apparences Mélania a un sacré caractère
et que et que du coup elle se laisse pas
faire par par Donald Trump c'est fort
hein fort non mais c'est bien c'est
intéressant et puis alors c'est pas
notre quand même parce que on sait très
bien que dans les relations entre les
président quand les premières dames
comme ça s'entendent bien ça peut
fluidifier au niveau de la diplomatie ça
peut décoincer un truc bah par exemple
regardez nous avec la Turquie c'est
quand même très compliqué voilà bah
quand elle dit ça là elle fait de la
politique parce que nous avec la Turquie
c'est très compliqué c'est très oui
exactement et quand elle dit ça c'est
une manière de dire bah voilà on peut
quand même parler et cetera donc c'est
aussi une interview politique c'est une
interview qui a du sens non fr elle est
très
forteors